staying in your house serving justice to
a man who stole your vibranium and
murdered your people just as your king
couldn't deliver I don't care that you
brought to call only reason I don't care
how high your standards because I know
who you are and now a special look at
Marvel Studios black panther my son it
is your time you get to decide what kind
of kingdoms you are going to be
oh I am ready confrontation ain't
nothing new to me a war is coming you
can bring a boy the biggest [ __ ] that's
them to me and I will be there deciding
as we die I'm into you're gonna need all
the help you can get
[Music]
you haven't seen anything yet good nice
pepper lady pg-13 everywhere February 16
and now a special look at Marvel Studios
Black Panther
my king stop it stop it are you taking
with you to Korea oh boy they're not
here as well you sure it's a good idea
to take your ex on a mission yes we'll
be fine
[Applause]
don't please they never freeze
[Music]
tell me who's gonna save me from myself
when this life
No
you get to decide kind of king you are
going to be
[Music]
Black Panther lady pg-13 everywhere
February 16
you